uncle's over here smoking a [ __ ]
joint of debt tamales con always from
urban trees they'll kill you
they'd dipped in formaldehyde [ __ ]
angel dust [ __ ] birds piss from the
Molly you got everything in these
[ __ ] things I'm celebrating sober
October greetings from podcast Ville the
church Oh what's happening now is
brought to you by my bookie listen if
you found the yardstick on the street
when you pick it up would you keep
walking of course you'd [ __ ] pick it
up why would you [ __ ] know why would
you keep picking winners and not betting
them all [ __ ] week you knew San
Francisco was gonna beat the Rams but
yesterday you said I'm not gonna bet cuz
I'm a [ __ ] and the bookmaking out is
where you get San Francisco winning
their bits like them if you're gonna
[ __ ] them back you got to go to my
bookie it's fast it's easy and they pay
when you win listen cut this [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] Tuesday morning start your week
with a bang right now go to my bookie
dot AG they double your first deposit
use promo code Church they get 100%
bonus on your initial deposit up to a
thousand dollars what the [ __ ] are you
waiting for go to my bookie dot AG today
not tomorrow not [ __ ] Thursday today
that's my bookie grab a pen cuz I know
you were dumb [ __ ] my B oo ki e dot AG
and don't forget to use promo code
Church when you're creating your account
to claim the bonus all right listen you
play you win you get paid the church
will happen now so we'll also love to
welcome athletic greens listen athletic
greens is a awesome supplement that
gives you big dick swing and energy if
you're not starting your day off with a
blast of vitamins you already lost
go back to bed [ __ ] but if you
want to feel tip-top Magoo and you want
those nuts to be filled with the [ __ ]
juju juice you gotta let athletic greens
do the dirty work they got you covered
over five critical areas out energy
immunity gut health and hormonal support
who takes care you like that nobody
[ __ ] up and do me a favor the church
family gets a special offer will they
give
20 free travel packs valued at $79 with
your first time purchase jump over to
athletic greens comm slash church and
get your travel packs today
that's athletic greens calm listen
athletic greens [ __ ] tremendous kick
this [ __ ] mule bleep it's
Tuesday morning you know I play this
song on my third on my morning rotation
every day for the last year it's
fantastic it gets me out of bed it makes
me want to stab my [ __ ] while
I'm drinking coffee that second cup of
coffee this [ __ ] comes out I go [ __ ]
robots I just sit there and think oh all
the [ __ ] that are going down
today I got a call on a column at 8:00
a.m. [ __ ] 901 you know saying
everybody's gonna correlate while
they're driving to the location I catch
him on the phone put that bluetooth on
[ __ ] Joey Diaz here Steve Simone here
and the [ __ ] here it's casual
[ __ ] Tuesday it's Taco Tuesday [ __ ]
Tuesday it's on the streets
whatever Tuesday you want it to be I'm
saying it's your [ __ ] Tuesday that's
I'm trying to say number one I want to
thank everybody who came out to the
shows at the Uptown Theater on Friday
night you were [ __ ] sensational and
then Denver Jesus [ __ ] Christ at the
Paramount you guys were tremendous she
touched my heart you know I left there
twenty four years ago on a car with
[ __ ] $8 in quarters and there I was
you know so in a way I lost the battle
but I won the war twenty four years
later I ended up getting what I was what
I wanted you know I never in my wildest
imagination some of the old comics they
used to do spots came out Wow
what we were talking about what we used
to do like how our open my seam was
let's see Simone we brought up something
I had forgotten about in those days you
know I would look at my notebook and I
knew something wasn't right because I
would only have like 16 17 spots okay I
would drive the [ __ ] Wyoming to do
spots and of all I would get was 16 4
spots a weakness Friday and Saturday you
were marked the ended the spots three
comedy clubs and Comedy Works wasn't
gonna give you
spot so you have McKelvey's or wit's end
wits and you rather put a gun in your
mouth and do just about that especially
The Late Show on a Friday was how long
and the other Club was like men's of
Malta and he was good to me I'm not
gonna lie he would give me a guest spots
but usually it was one spot and then we
hung like to celebrate it yeah but I
heard about people doing multiple spots
and it intrigued me so I said wait a
second the hot thing in those days was
line dancing
mm-hmm and we followed a wine dancing
class on Sundays you do comedy after
line dancing in [ __ ] Havana at some
like country-western it was rough and
the whole place would disappear Billy
Ray Cyrus's on everybody's dancing yeah
awesome and she would go five minutes
comedy style God and you would see the
whole room clear up nothing better for
you open mike eagle ah but what we did
that was big time that I [ __ ] laughed
my ass off on the plane yesterday was we
used to crash karaoke bars yeah karaoke
was huge in 93 and 94 and opened poetry
readings were big in 93 and 94 the more
you went away from Boulder the looser
they got cuz Boulder people were very
serious white people were very serious
about poetry oh yeah all those rich kids
they had a couple bars that did poetry
night and mostly cafes this is way
before Starbucks this is no Starbucks
balda had the coffee houses with the
couches and the books and Bolger was
called Penny Lane and it was tremendous
and I was in the halfway house with an
old [ __ ] forger the old Jew from New
York oh my gosh from the old school
Hendricks at the Somme or that type of
epi Wow still had the long hair he if I
was it was 90 it was 1980 it was 91 I
met him when I was 27 he was already 55
a dog he had a bangin outlook on a
six-year-old chick with blue eyes
she was beautiful she never wore bras
she had had on their armpits
she was the merese hippy hippy so she
ran the poetry minute
guess what I'm Friday and Saturday it
stayed open 24 hours and the poetry
reading started at 11:00 so when he says
as when I when I got into comedy I got
into comedy I wasn't even involved
really in the probation system anymore
but I was still dear friends with him
okay but he was too old to go out at
night so he would always go I'm kind of
scared that she's down there alone this
coffee shop and like don't listen you
know tiles I put me on the poetry
readings and I'm a good honest sign up
and I'm [ __ ] 40 yeah and I get there
early and I get a notebook out and right
and then she would slip me into the
poetry readings and they would laugh
really
wait you they were doing their like
poetry and you would just go up and do a
stand-up set yeah coming up Tuesday's
next Joey Diaz go up we never you gotta
watch a Godzilla movie
I would just start [ __ ] ranting and
they would be looking right that's not
poetry guy they never said nothing to me
because she ran it gotcha
but the more you went outside a boulder
they got looser and looser there's one
in particular right by a hundred and
forty oh I'm fourth and Thornton but
there was a wall there hmm I used to go
to that mall a lot because they used to
sell cars in Thornton so when you were
bored you took all the cars in the lot
you went to the mall you went the
sparrows yeah you've got a slice walking
around that craziness is [ __ ] and around
the block and that mall was a coiffure
that guy hated when we did comedy so we
would wait like he would start to show
it like eight uh-huh and then he would
leave he was the element he would sit
there for line we knew the thing ran
till 10:00 and we would catch different
baristas if they didn't know us hi oh I
would like to sign up for karma he wants
a nut vanilla you know leti cuz you
couldn't just get black coffee I knew
you were crazy if you didn't get one of
their green tea [ __ ] mixes then they
go oh you like green tea oh my god I
drink the orchid milk I started with
that [ __ ] yeah and then they would
let you go you can't get out
no more that guy threw us out ten times
at one time like we grabbed each other
like you say I'm not gonna tell you
again to stay out here with you [ __ ]
r-rated joke I kept talking [ __ ] I got
my rights [ __ ] you know I was
just doing it to break his balls in
comedy because there were people who
came up to me like men and women they
must never one woman in particular came
up to me and she goes I don't know what
your name is you killed me tonight the
crowd didn't know what I think I've
never seen that reaction to a person but
you can't come in on low because some of
these are the complaint and I shook her
hand she gave me like a kid she gave me
a free coffee yes she was I don't mind
that yeah yeah take yeah I just couldn't
take the people who would just plan our
route to me like that dude yeah so we
would go there like I was telling
somebody yesterday then we started
tag-team in karaoke joint with do you do
stand-up at karaoke and they really get
pissed you want to piss somebody off
when they're wet cuz there's people
really serious I've got great voices
they just made a wrong turn they go up
there there's duo's that sing like Kenny
Rogers
they sing endless love yeah so I still
remember I go in there with the
intention like you knew there was gonna
be a problem so alright so there's 30
people signed up for the karaoke so
obviously you're already tanked you got
a grandma blowing your pocket you're
just taking a chance so Lee would be
number 28 Joey Diaz would be 32 and
Steve Simone would be 35 we wait for Lee
Lee to go up then the song would be
playing in mine
yeah I see no but I'll spot you you know
that I like a little background saying
yeah yeah and the big screen you're up
to eighth I haven't taken by Godzilla
New Jersey and then just looking at you
why the music and the words are coming
up on the screen but you're doing
stand-up and the DJ was just looking
like you know like he would like so if
Lee got away with it the DJ Mag I give
lease at around the pause right then we
go right now number 32 is me so we let
to say
go up yeah and they would sing their
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then they would get
off and hug each other coming to the
stage Joey Diaz leg up though let me
talk to you my second you [ __ ] on
this [ __ ] then I would push the envelope
even father so if I got or sometimes
they would just put the music on loud or
scratched it you know what the guy Evers
try to sit over you get off get off yeah
no vocal material on the stage right off
get off and we would just go to another
karaoke place now you would be first
switch the order on so everybody got a
set everybody got a set it and Lee would
go up second and by the time they didn't
stand on the lead then I would go up
third one or that how many spots do you
think you got from that it was always
like you it wasn't a spot you were gonna
get tortured they won't even it let me
know about prep and let me know the
different levels of comedy okay it lets
you know that okay when you go to a bar
and do stand-up mm-hmm Danite there to
see you right there to watch the hockey
game and to have a few drinks yeah
Monday nights dark night Tuesday nights
girls night Wednesday night's comedy
night there's a nice cocaine night and
Friday night just kill yourself doing
the [ __ ] you want night they're not
really prepared for calmly
psychologically yeah okay when I go on
probably stored calm and I look at the
schedule and I buy tickets let my two
tickets a whole different mindset I'm
getting prepared
Absalon I completely agree yeah put the
CD on you put you know but Christ you
see dear Theo von all that stuff makes a
difference all of them yeah so you
always as a comic you also you also have
to study the psychology of people yeah I
learned that in those rooms that if you
got one laughs you want yeah even you
know what's the song three minutes
yeah if you got one laughs at the minute
mark you want some people you know get
the [ __ ] off right like like I said to
you Gary oh he's very serious to some
people at the time Oh still like I won't
even try to sing karaoke because I'm
terrible and some people take that as an
offense
I have a mutual friend that taste is
karaoke seriously and every year of his
birthday he has a karaoke birthday party
that he posted up and he'll tell you
he's actually singing living on a prayer
bon jovi like they're people really and
I don't I'm not laughing at them I'm not
laughing at them all that's an out
that's a great form of uh I think that's
great I love when anybody loves
something you know if that if that
brings you some joy and like that is
awesome
one of the toughest guys I know lives
for he met his wife at a karaoke no no
no it's amazing so it taught me the
psychology economy in 1994 like I
learned the state of mental of the per
you know how many you know you're not
gonna turn off a dumb enough you can no
you're not turning up nobody's payment
no won't even think of you know in those
days what saved you is that there was no
Sunday night game okay
there was no Sunday Night Football game
so a lot of open mics on Sundays okay
and the area I moved to the area I would
go to they would go stay on Sunday
there's tons open mikes on Sundays
because there wasn't that 5:30 NFL
family and so but if Denver was playing
at night you're done you know if Denver
played in the afternoon don't want a
clock game that open mic was gonna be
phenomenal
yeah plus there was no big that there's
gonna be a couple drunk people because
they just pulled over for the whole day
so you're gonna have a problem you know
I'm saying when you started you figure
this out
little by little yes and I started to
realize it all everything matters and I
started to see the rules of the game
that if you could just stick it out if
you could just persevere it got a little
bit easier at every level like if you
were doing an open mic where it was just
comics and you only had two or three
minutes spot if you got one laughs that
you're a king but then a step up would
be there used to be a bar show down by
Val surf in that little strip mall
there's like a Chinese restaurant it's
like right on the LA River they would do
a bar show like on Tuesday nights or
something like that but there would be
maybe eight real people in there
and I and I would go oh this is better
than doing an open my kick our Gulch in
front of just comics cuz even though
it's in a bar there's real people's our
coach I think it's still going on I
think it is yet that Miyagi's or
whatever there was that jab he was
begging for people to take a night in
there for a while yes give you like
episode of the door but he'd only give
me two bucks when any people show that
yes weird yeah I walked offstage to that
normal is that yeah I never even walked
in I just heard all the [ __ ] nonsense
that went with it yeah I was harmed that
went with it and I was like you know
there's also people who book The Improv
like then Here I am in LA 20 years later
and I get an offer from The Improv it
was 2000 okay Dan oh yeah dan from Brea
yeah called me one day he goes I have a
weird feeling about you I want you to
host a dirty show I remember that it was
Wednesday night sorry one Wednesday a
month and I started learning about
commitment hmm I started learning about
the commitment from people who paid the
tickets oh that was give me that free
kick absolutely it's a different rooms a
big that's a huge difference you can
even see that at the store when they do
those early shows sometimes they'll go
use this code word for a free ticket or
a $5 ticket huge difference because
they're not they're not invested yeah
the more they're invested the better the
audience it's so weird how long I went
to Rochester one time like I was
learning how to book this room he would
tell me you got about I'm gonna give you
like three months of a guarantee mmm
good after that you have to figure it
out in your songs everything everybody
had to get paid yeah anyway there was
times I walked out of my own room with
25 bucks because I paid everybody I
don't give a [ __ ] am saying a meal you
got a tip to waitstaff yeah bucks yeah I
got eight people drinking who don't
bring their friend
yeah who's nice but I I learned a lot
because he I after about the fifth one I
had like 14 people in there cuz I'm like
wow did the road I went to Rochester
and the guy at the Rochester Club was
crazy whatever one thing he said to me
goes I don't do nothing for free because
I'd rather do a show with ten paid
regular than a hundred people didn't
back yeah he goes when you come into my
club you have to give me something a
watch $3 $5 $10 because I will not give
away a free ticket gotta be looking at
him as crazy as he was his personal life
yeah and going he's on this--on that's
true
and then was the creation of me learning
how to sell a ticket now you have to
build that value and say how do you
build that value so it's really weird
how the lesson is taught to you yeah you
see that you need commitment from people
people go I was a shitty show well they
weren't dare to watch comedy exactly
whatever check up on him and you bumped
into their checker dog right and as a
young comic I used to I didn't realize
how important the audience was to my
performance the psychology of the
audience and then I even started to just
by working the door at the store oh my
god Tuesday nights got a different
energy than a Saturday night people that
get there early you could even see
people that were getting to the club
early that really wanted to be there
they were better audience members than
people you know how the store would keep
the o.r go and sometimes drunk people
just walk by and walk in and didn't know
what they were getting themselves into
it all matters all of it matters even
the way the rooms are laid out you know
like that the height of the stage though
the ceilings how cliff like Wayne
Wayne's room this weekend in Reno I'm
like he just sat the people graduations
thank you for taking away with I was a
really great time it was so much fun but
we drove 17 I was a good wife and a
speeding ticket he's got blisters on his
[ __ ] on his ass
he did great I talked to him last night
I could hear this voice that you feel
the bumps and the humps and just sitting
there
you got a stretch out after every time
you you know cuz I would drive a gallon
I would drive a tank my rule is I don't
stop to attack his Ani
okay I have a question for you about
that though did you ever run on a gas
because I did that on the way up and I
got real close I was
like 40 miles an hour you gotta pay
attention also you have to pay attention
if you see you're at low and they're
like this is the last gasp eighty
thousand miles
yeah you gotta go but always have those
signs and get some feet and stretch our
man with three phone calls let your
blood it's just processing yes you're
you don't you can get hypnotized on the
world like you gotta get your first
night
yes good night so that's why I told them
there you go and it's a it's uh driving
to comedy gigs it's a complete different
[ __ ] animal you know I love when
people drive for a living
like my friend Timmy tries for a living
and people drive for a living I always
give them a lot of respect because I
tended for you know I drove from 94 to
2003 and then Rogen and then you know
this guy and then eventually you know
but I pretty much [ __ ] in his row
I remember finally like in 2004 the club
in like something Pennsylvania called me
and I agreed to the week and somebody
told me like he got landed Noah to drive
three hours out of life it looks like
I'm canceling that [ __ ] I didn't cancel
till Friday at 6:00 oh my god yeah I was
so scared that can't me like we knew it
we already had somebody here plus you
were gonna be dirty we didn't want you
anyway I was like so we both walk yeah
what are we talking about they hired me
they watch the tape and there were like
oh my god they called me up like if you
come you have to change your material
some part of Pennsylvania and juniors
comedy club or something
Oh like I'm here here so yeah like that
yeah I've heard of that oh yeah and now
a woman owns it she's a little bit more
liberal she lets you go off
she gives door deals but in those days
it was run by guys oh it they they play
the banjo anybody who plays a banjo you
don't want to talk to them you plays
like a banjo and tells you like they
kind of creep you somewhere they got a
kid in the basement think they got a
grandma an attic somewhere with a gag on
the fall them those banjo people [ __ ]
crazy yeah I don't think I've met any
that's good yes yeah they just don't
identify that
don't say right off the bat they play
the banjo you gotta tell them somewhere
your secrets first I kill butterflies
it's great to see you by the way great
to be hanging out with you guys oh
you're doing great things we get a
little charity not one thing about your
charity that I really like and I haven't
donated yet because I'm still figuring
out my wife for me we're talking about
this
yeah I'm really picky about my donations
I don't blame him
I'm very picky because I do not like
what I see most this is this is a bold
statement I'm gonna make I know that
most people will he male me or whatever
and say it's a bold statement but every
time I see a tragedy mm-hmm I say to
myself some swim is gonna make them
really exactly and it breaks my heart I
see them out there giving away water and
supplies and all this [ __ ] on Mike
Katrina a Mike said sure enough the man
grabbed a million point nine million
dollars you know I know and it bothers
the [ __ ] out of me yeah when JJ did the
Houston one I donated to his yeah
football player yeah JJ why I don't like
talking about this [ __ ] on the air
because I don't want people to think I'm
just trying to prove a point about
something to talk to Steve about it
because I think that what he's doing
with all things calm you know you want
love do you get a lot of support over
there yeah it's very special
I don't I believe that if you have a
lone prophet and the president drives a
better car than me
absolutely there's no something's not
right there's not right I completely get
your 125 hundred thousand a year that's
most of the people you help yeah I think
if you want to do an organization you
should have a day job yeah I do that I'm
happy with that so you know I would do
something if I had time it's somewhere
along the line something's gonna get
caught out yeah but if I could do
something one day a week for shelter or
cat shelter yeah or something like that
I'd be involved exact what I'm not gonna
give you 300 hours for your earthquake
relief system I know there's a white
[ __ ] somewhere dude yeah I'm not just
gonna blame white people black news got
sticky fingers too or a [ __ ] Latino
and
or an Arab or whatever yeah that's
taking my [ __ ] money that's supposed
to be going to help somebody's a little
[ __ ] really need their lights turn
taps yeah no I look at the homeless
situation here in Los Angeles
they've given that man millions of
dollars for that homeless thing we pay
some [ __ ] high state taxes yes and
number two I want to know what they've
done with the medical marijuana lot of
money yeah you know Colorado gives you a
yearly report these people don't even
bring it up yeah and what they do my
wife finally looks it up I go see how
they break it up yeah and she told me
how they broken of marijuana education
something like that toss cans for so
somebody's lining their pockets listen
so I'm a thief you know I've come to the
conclusion that I was the thief when I
was a kid yeah and now I see as soon as
there's a [ __ ] tragedy and I see a
number you know I got a B on C even the
Red Cross I heard that there's
discrepancy all of them I've heard of
this discrepancies in the Red Cross
years ago all of it it tears me apart
yeah and I see people with Lorene's and
hurricanes and [ __ ] so before I send a
dollar like chris herren lee how quickly
take me to send the dollar cuz i know
what he's doing yeah I know that dude
that dude is not driving a [ __ ]
Corvette alright that dude really
believes in his cause and again we sent
money this year for the church that's
great oh huh I don't mind helping you
out you know but I wanted to get to
those people's eyes I said [ __ ] the
black guy from The Fugees robbed this
[ __ ] it's a it's a very easy
temptation that's why I like it was a
very easy temptation I went I didn't
even want to touch the money like with
this last family I don't even know
what's happening with this I just saw
people that needed help that that were
good people people that are always
helping other people like this mom I
found out about she's got six kids four
of them are sick one of them's really
sick she wasn't asking for a dollar for
herself she's running all we're doing a
party at the Ronald McDonald House
Friday night I got the pizzas donated
from a couple buddies but that's who she
is she's always there's a family with a
sick kid that is a homeless living in a
motel she would take half of what she
has to go feed that family
when it was another mom a Children's
Hospital that told me about her I was
getting one family money and I put the
money straight to the mom I said what's
your venmo I'm gonna do a GoFundMe for
you and I essentially just vouched for
these people and I brought a little
awareness but the money didn't touch any
organization and went straight to a mom
I went straight to a mom that lost a kid
that works at the hospital had had
nothing and the landlord kicked them out
of her house so they got into a new
place but there was no furniture nothing
so I was like if I could get her five
grand breathing room great and that's
all I tried to do we got her to about
3,800 $4,200 and she went Steve I feel
blessed thank you very much I'm okay
I can breathe you have to help Monique
out and then I I got to meet Monique and
I went on her social media and she had a
GoFundMe up for another family she
wasn't even thinking about herself and I
went okay that's who I'm gonna help I'm
gonna help the people that are always
helping others that don't ask for
anything and the money is going to go
straight to them
nobody's gonna do the fun you have right
now it's just caught our magical bought
the domain name for help Steve help I'm
asking people to follow that on Twitter
and Instagram just follow it for now and
then our game plan is gonna be we're
gonna do a podcast once a month do a
patreon for $1 a month and you're gonna
get the podcast so I'm just asking
people to give a buck once a month but
for now go to help Steve help on
Instagram and Twitter and then we're
gonna put the family up of the month
you're gonna give $1 and that money's
gonna go straight to the family if we
build it up and there's gonna be extra
money like instead of because I think
5,000 is enough breathing room for
somebody and then we'll help the next
family and if we have to cycle family
through three or four times because the
problems are real and the money goes
fast I understand that but the band-aid
is five grand it's going to go straight
to them and then if there's extra money
how do you check the arms and smell
their neck and make sure that's smoking
Wow oh yeah but that that's the other
problem because I bill that's what bill
Berg reached out to me because he was I
think this will evolve into something
for the homeless situation as well
because he goes our politic
led us down he goes these charities are
all scams because I know you're not in
this for anything because I bill was
like I want to help people I've lived
the American dream
he goes we have to do some job training
we have to make sure that people aren't
addicts he goes I don't have a problem
with addicts I know they're suffering
but he goes the problems if you give an
addict money you're gonna kill him
because he goes do you think you're
gonna help and you're gonna wind up
killing that's like and I listened read
I don't know how many times because I
was an addict I throw it I had it
toiling to make this day yeah go get a
fix I don't know what it's like they're
gonna fix of the sandwich or so yes I've
been there I get it that's true
compassion but I don't want to give
fifty thousand it's always one addict
exactly just show me a picture of that
child with you puts little red dots on
them told you that's why right now and
next thing you know if I got people on
my like I got in trouble five years ago
on Twitter yeah somebody reported me
that the go fund me use that credit card
you know and I was shocked like I was
blown the [ __ ] away I had like four or
five emails in a row like that the
California Attorney if I knew this
person I'm like no they just told me to
retweet so now exactly listen just leave
me alone
I know I'm not do it right now and I do
it because these are people who just
they show you a picture of a dude that's
laying in a bed with a skeleton
yeah meanwhile these people in [ __ ]
Hollywood some lobster tails and you
know again I don't mind some throwing
somebody at Tony I don't mind making
somebody's day yeah
but there's people on Twitter they're
really getting in their car and they
changing oils yeah and they're more lost
their money and they give you twenty
dollars and I hope you're not [ __ ]
you know so when you donate you know
listen every time I see a tragedy or
something I can't I give it like three
or four days yeah because there's people
that are waiting their rate on your
numbers all ready to go yep I know how
it's done I read a thing years ago in
the New York Times how they busted this
is like cerebral palsy thing mm-hmm
like they were living like kings and
traveling around the world they would
coming back to make withdrawal it's
awful and then I sold things for the
cops in Seattle I went in there was a
Salesman
they paid me you know twenty five
percent commission what I brought in and
I had done it I'm very ashamed list so
he's damned very ashamed it's because
this is the [ __ ] I'm ashamed hmm I'm not
ashamed
well that broke into a drug dealers
house they had come and we were drug
dealers this is the [ __ ] that really
makes me ashamed of things sometimes
yeah well I live in Seattle I they were
looking for telemarketers and I went
down there and they give you a pitch and
it's high dome were calling from North
Hollywood Police Department and we're
looking for donations for a new program
for school kids and you know because
when I was a kid I remember them giving
you the sticker when I was a kid if you
donated to the fire department yes they
gave you a sticker for your window
that's oh yeah yeah yeah children of
this rule like a silver sticker if you
donated five bucks 1970 yeah you got
like a little badge for the fire
department and you got a sticker for
your window that said children in the
room and so they hopefully they'd save
you first
I'll tell grandma I go [ __ ] so I
always learned from all those things you
know I sold stick this to see you I hope
and I donate the money yes you know I
told my daughter about three weeks ago
and this is no [ __ ] lie well I got
thrown out of Catholic school I had such
a deep guilt at my heart mmm
but I connected myself with the American
Heart Association and every headed the
walkathon my goal was to break the
record and you had a walk around Hudson
County Park and I would walk at 40
[ __ ] times and I would get everybody
in my mother's bar to give everybody why
are you just supposed to get a dime a
mile [ __ ] you I want a dollar but I want
Awards till about 10 to 13 then I
started stealing the money myself
then I'll go their [ __ ] age we're
gonna walk I got the money in my pocket
as I will make them pay me upfront know
what I'm gonna walk 15 miles yeah I'm
gonna walk 25 miles but I gotta be
honest with you for the first three
years I really didn't give her the money
hey they gave me the thing they took a
picture I won like the highest achiever
yeah really [ __ ] made my dick hard in
those Catholic years when I got thrown
out of Catholic school so I told mercy
I'm gonna walk the walkathon this year
with her and get money you know you know
10 miles would have identical walk maybe
three miles if I'm lucky she'll give me
like five hours a mile or something like
that you know so but I believe in that
you know me too it feels good to help
you good it feels good I have that's a
good help well yeah I've had plenty of
friends over the last four or five years
and call me Val and I've always said let
me call you back
mm-hmm I've thought about this situation
I've thought about their life and I've
always helped yeah because I have to
think of what they meant to me when I
was growing up mmm with no with no
disregard I have to write a check like I
can't even think about it you know
because of what they did to me as a
child so even now there's not much I can
do for the homeless problem yeah you
know you want me go get a bus and go
pick them all up where am I gonna take
them [ __ ] else I can't yeah I don't
have any answers but I know that this
[ __ ] state you know I'd like to have
a talk with that knew some guy I'd like
to have a talk with the other [ __ ]
governor you know you have to get buses
and get people over the train to go talk
to these people and you know first it
wasn't needed
I appreciate the army building two
houses I am on a weekend but that's not
fast enough
we need dormitory style you know old
Jim's show yeah keep the people at the
homeless you know the people that you're
helping yeah I want them separated from
mental health okay the homeless
situation is three degrees of
homelessness yeah you're right it's Tico
enemy drug homelessness and mental
health hopelessness that's what I think
as a what has observer I agree don't
look norm we r gonna take the 101 when
you make that right to take the 101
there's a pretty [ __ ] lady that walks
around with a bikini and a thing and at
first you look at her and you go who you
know you like whoa what the [ __ ] she's
got month ago she washes her [ __ ]
shoes on the street I saw the one
morning putting bottled water on her
feet her feet were black you know that's
mental health that's not somebody who
went to eat have lost his job the kid
got it you know there's a lot of people
buy no whole part that live in the
trailers now that's it people with Lars
and Arthur they leave the daytime they
go there the daytime they leave at night
you don't have to park that no more the
trailer thing not so bad there it lay
that the cops pull up signs those people
are homeless those people
ten years ago Fannie Mae whatever that
were at 2008 don't collapse all those
people that said you know what we're
gonna take the last $22,000 I mean
savings and buy some type of use thing
and until we figure this out cuz I used
to lift weights over there I used to
walk law and I would stop and talk to
those people they won't tell me the
stories and it would say yeah you know
we lost a home but for anything that's
hardly fun that was so right now in Los
Angeles you know there's weed money I
know in Colorado it's so [ __ ] tight
it's to the seed and they show you where
it goes to school on this and that here
since we went legal I haven't heard
nothing about it I don't mind paying
tithing you know that dog go to [ __ ] in
the old perennial and get an eight to
weed and come back to me thank God I got
an urban trees they give me like a deal
you know they pound the taxes on it but
the deal they give me stupid they give
me a great deal go to a regular weed
store as a recreational user see how
expensive it is let's see how expensive
the taxes on your life it's 25 percent
no no no 35:23 I think some way through
because there's so there's I think it's
ten percent from medical and then I
think it's like to either 25 or 35 from
recreational and the the thing for Steve
because I know you've been on
in the past couple years but in case
people are new you met these families at
Children's Hospital they weren't like
submitting like you you met some of
these people who really need ya and the
way we're verifying is it we don't just
have people pay it forward so the family
we're helping now we'll go okay well
here's another mom that needs the five
thousand and then when we get that
family to help then they nominate the
next family but I think look it's just
in it's baby steps
I pray that and hope that it'll grow
into something great but for right now
it's all people that really need the
money that have fallen through the
cracks
they're truly victims you know that's
the saddest thing ever there's sick kids
and people don't realize all the bills
associated over that because usually if
a parent's working they might have to
stop working right off the bat to take
care of the kid there's gas back and
forth to the hospital
there's the but it's 10 15 bucks day
just to park at the hospital so I have
big dreams of what I think it could turn
into but for right now I the family I'm
helping right now I just shared the moms
venmo and I've got her a GoFundMe and
the money went straight there I had a
couple of my buddies that own the
Italian deli that owned the pizza place
that have fed the families we've done
little parties for the families at those
places and that's it give the kids
something look forward to you know
that's it
I was telling you that with the Seattle
and I had that out I worked through
these guys and I was making money you
know six hundred week every time we
turns I can tell disgusting you're going
correctly can I be on your list like
down the list like the number 200 for
these parts so I think these garlic
parsley tablets you're supposed to take
two for you to clean out your system I
take to reach work they're gonna see me
take the heavy side you know so I got to
take three or more if you think that
whippin is taking my back no I'll lift
Satterwhite from the [ __ ] substance to
me
so I work with these guys this isn't and
you know it was great for about six
months I did great I showed up every day
and basically the pitch was a shakedown
yeah it was a pitch that you have
business you wanted the police to
support you so if you put this PBA
sticker on your window or your car mmm
they would know you supported the police
department well then and I would sell
[ __ ] to one of our hands-free I don't
wanna sell ads Jack you know and one day
I said let me actually look at this
newspaper this newspaper will look like
it cost welcome to the two cents to make
him like it was like some kid made it
with crayon and then I asked one of the
guys that worked any good he didn't know
the scam they give you 25% and they
pretty much keep 65% and give the other
10% to a charity all three elements have
BMW and Alexis's and convertibles I
remember every guy and I live on the way
out I am before I go for like I was
leaving on a Sunday and I went to one of
the guys that robbed me for [ __ ]
eight months and he was robbing people
and one guy became friendly with me he
would come to the Seattle calmly think
well he was a piece of [ __ ] I knew him
and like the weekend I left I said yo I
need a big favor from you I'm moving can
I get two weeks salary advance to me and
he goes what do you make a week ago my
600 cuz I write you a check for 12 June
chain yep well so many of those places
that's how they operate that's all I
only give like there's a percentage by
law that they have to give when you
realize that percentage people if you
look it up it's my heart will break you
belong in a second if I donate a hundred
hours the person that I'm donating to
after all the funnels and paperwork and
[ __ ] only basically it's hot well
there's also whisper down the line so
like there's organizations that'll say
they'll do what you did and then they
make that
nation of the 15 bucks out of a hundred
to the American Heart Association thing
like even these establish good charities
like a buddy of mine he doesn't give
money to charities he's got a lot of
money because his buddy ran some big
famous charity one of the household name
ones they had a $50,000 mahogany desk no
I know this is what I'm talking about so
that's why I see that I'm just putting
it right in the mom's pocket that's it
if this is going to pay bills his
putting gas in the car food on the table
car seats like the family were helping
now soon as a check came in for me and I
went all right I can I can afford to
give a cert and she showed me the car
seats that she bought with the money I
gave her I know buddy's touching it at
the car wash I told you stick to the
[ __ ] script you know and I'm
like sitting there going this guy's like
a [ __ ] pimp and I still remember
getting caught up one of those things
one day with this fat disgusting dude
this dude him and his sister both of
them tipping the scales at 500 I don't
want to say his name Bonnie from North
Bergen she came through when they she
saying that you wanna make money my
brother makes money and all that and he
was just ugly as [ __ ]
fat is [ __ ] then her brother was a
slob just like all over the sides her
brother made Ralphie look small yeah and
all he would do is sit in that car and
smoke cigarettes and drink milkshakes
from Carvel he would have three of those
things in his [ __ ] car at one time
Jesus he was huge so what he would do is
drive you into a neighborhood and you
would knock on doors to get newspaper
subscriptions and he would give him like
25 cents a subscription and I Murph or
Kelly we had to meet him at 9:00 and
then work till 12:00 but that day he
picked three gangsters
gonna be picked at the wrong three
gangsters yeah yeah who he picked but
like we were like 12 o'clock we take
some lunch he's like I don't do lunch
away
yo fat boy you do look caliber you guys
we would like to like 13 that's going
like in the 8th grade
he called like the three wrong guys I
forget I wish I could remember who we
had I remember but will I go we're
eating now cuz we all work with
different people in the neighborhood and
the street code was whatever you hire
kids enable you gotta feed them lunch
yeah I got a pizza
yeah good sandwiches from the deli
that's what I was trying to tell me
about when I took me on the road he goes
why if I go it's the code I go the
headliner always has to pay code if we
go to the movies I go lead put your
money away well you're not gonna pay for
this - when I go you have to the
headliner buys the meals if the
headliner asked you to the movies we
gotta pay exact clothes someday you just
pay it forward you'll be paying me off
or some creature act yourself exactly it
all comes back yeah you know I thank Joe
Rock Joe Rogan bought me more stakes
than my mother did that's in fact Joe
Rogan bought me more 4000 stakes and my
mother did lots of I remember Joe Rogan
taking us out to that diner I don't even
know a diner existed in that what's that
fancy hotel right across the street from
the store the standard that's this
starving
cheeseburger yes Joe goes like this
oh I don't even know what was in there
I've been there you ordered everything
everyone got the menu he could get two
of those no it was access smooth areas
we were and it was the only meal I'd
have all day I never I'll forever be
grateful we need a walk - he would make
this walk the [ __ ] standing because
it wasn't worth getting out of the thing
like hate of us understands it but the
blue cheese murder standard with the
French fries off I know it 20 years ago
guys this is 19 this is Newsradio 98
standard or pink that was guaranteed if
he wasn't alone to walk I would get off
Stu he would watch my spot yeah at 1:30
and then we'd had to pink that and get
the meatball parm
the roast beef sandwich my god I
remember you that's when because you
knew I was starving you gave me half
your sandwich because I was managing the
club then yes and you water then you go
here do yourself a favor because I was
living off those peanuts mitts he would
sell in the red in the red plastic bags
that's all I had to eat all day
don't forget reading Tennyson's book and
him talking about him and call a bow get
to the store at 7:00 and eat the fruit
yeah bartenders bartenders would cut
that's how hungry they were yeah and I
remember finding myself when they put
extra limes and a coke like vitamins
like I'm so broke you don't want to get
scurvy I'm eating [ __ ] when these
burgers for lunch I gotta put some type
of vitamins real food it was hot who
told me you could I talk to you and Huff
used to do coke and have false teeth
yeah so we'll each snort coke the false
teeth would shatter and it's not
tremendously a lot of time so Huck was
the first person that haven't told me
goes you know I can't buy you you don't
not get dude says he's I offended if I
tell you he goes you drink too much soda
hmm he was the first person ever had the
balls he goes the other night I count
the 14/15 sotas you have to stop wow
that's like okay and I started drinking
died and he's like not diet bad too yeah
let's meet halfway so whatever he would
be on shift I drink Jack and Coke but
diet you know and he's the first person
that told me get to all your - this is
20 years ago and he was something you're
too old to be drinking soda know that I
loved Huck so much loved him were you
there the night he dropper and is easy
with the all those guys are Thai boxers
he dropped what is easy with a liver
kick go on quarters feet I've never seen
a human being fall like that because
precise those Muay Thai guys he grew up
to knock knock kicking trees down any
Tony know we would try to hold love and
he had the strength of ten [ __ ]
elephants every one of those things that
you hold something you are tied
knock it off I can't do this like he was
really pushing me and I was 300 pounds
and he was moving rings going after
Tripoli that night it was probably Tony
Tony was like the middle one
yeah well that was like Bruce Lee like
yes you look like the guy who played
Bruce Lee Kris whatever his name and he
had a sinister laugh Tony loved me to
come in and watch my sets and you just
go like that those are weird times those
are weird when he told me about the
[ __ ] sodas I was like thank you man
either you come in for 6 million week
thank $15 but he thought that's a lot
from 8:00 to 10:00 and then you go home
and you're up to a 4 pushing all that
can't not now but now I'm really happy
and proud of you that you're doing this
because I know that you're doing it out
of it nothing bothers me more when
people take the cause yeah it's all I
see right through it yeah you know
listen I like people who do things and
nobody asked at all
that's exactly you know what the truth
is what I do something Oh nobody leaves
nobody's business that's it
I'll put it behind us on there yeah well
all my stuff you know you got to do
something to let people know don't do
you doing it for the wrong and that's
this whole thing I'm very leery about
because of one person spends the money
the wrong way one person does something
al bought the name help Steve help I
didn't want my name on it I didn't even
want to put anything out there but
they're my buddies salad I don't zap
it's a place downtown he went and we
were talking and he's a smart guy
self-made guy because I understand
everything you're saying but he goes you
have to be more concerned that that mom
they can't afford a car he's gonna get a
car so she can go to visit her kid and
get her kid to the hospital than what
anybody else says or thinks but if I was
rich I wouldn't I would just do it I
would just pay it without anybody
knowing that's the whole reason why I
wanted to get into this business was to
help people but I was like I might never
become rich and these people still need
help so I used to give what I could give
and then a couple years ago a podcast
listener sent me a couple hundred bucks
at Christmas it was Thanksgiving I was
in the stinky motel I took
a gig at the Mall of America three
months in advance November yeah I'm open
in November and I realized it was
Thanksgiving weekend so I'm sitting in
the motel that they knocked down since
knocked down it was horrible it's one of
those motels where the floor wasn't even
this wasn't the new wall America no it
was across the parking lot from the new
Mall of America it was horrible they
knocked it down and built a nicer hotel
but I was in that hotel a podcast
listener just heard me say something
about visiting a family at the hospital
she goes I want my kids to know the
value of giving is it all right if I
send can I PayPal you a little donation
so they know I know yeah I thought it
was gonna be 25 bucks or something $250
$400 so then first time I ever shared
anything on social media because I don't
want anybody know what I was doing I
want does anybody ever hook up with
Playstations
cuz now I thought if somebody kept me an
employee discount I could buy two of
them and I could help both families
immediately my buddy Carlo from the
Italian deli sends me a message he goes
there's two point brand-new Playstations
at the deli
pick him up he was used that money for
other gifts then and Ruth Ellis who
produces Bill Birds podcast goes I think
we should do something with this he goes
bill hates normal charities he doesn't
trust him he goes but he trusts you
after Wow that's how terrible is that
that will make in that state everybody
says it he's a well-known thing it's a
well-known thing it's [ __ ] horrible
that's the world we live in
it's [ __ ] horrible like in my deepest
darkest the [ __ ] moments
I wouldn't even face something like that
now like the guy who scammed me put like
a kid up with tubes and [ __ ] and I'm
like who thinks this up like in my
darkest [ __ ] moments I'd rather rob
you with a gun absolutely I've always
had a [ __ ] thing
if you come a robbery with a gun I'll
get with you yeah but don't try the
[ __ ] con he was something like that
so I remember going back and looking at
the thing because they sent me
everything in the email that I had
retweeted one day that what timing yeah
I don't know how the guy got caught I
don't know what the father was but I
remember how like I felt stupid and I
felt taken because you can't help
everybody you know every little bit
counts
absolutely well it kills your spirit too
that's the problem like you mess up once
and then people go forget it I'm not
gonna give that a charity I'm not gonna
trust anybody so it's it's it's horrible
there's there they're killing the
kindness and he just told you a story of
me admitting to you guys me borrow money
from a guy that I knew I was not gonna
give money to right regardless of
whether the guy was a good guy or a bad
guy my deed should not be applauded we
giggled here because you know who I am
right I've done some very cold-blooded
things I called burr things but they've
always been to people in a way who had
it coming
they got themselves involved over the
head there was some few unfortunates
there were some good people came up to
me and said I want to be a cocaine
investor right what do I get if I give
you ten thousand twenty thousand and
you're gonna come up to me and give me
ten thousand I gotta take it of me and
if you're gonna be that stupid you
reminded me of Paulie walnuts when he
goes purgatory because soldiers don't go
to hell for killing other soldiers
that's what you're doing with soldiers
this always so just a soldier so but
putting up a gang war saying that you're
a CEO you know whatever of a non-profit
ah I find that you're driving a [ __ ]
convertible Bheema my blood pressure
goes zero [ __ ] my buddy that started the
regular hero charity the only money that
doesn't go straight to the cause is to
the accountant and to the lawyer he
lives in his art studio and he doesn't
have a car so like when we would do a
fundraiser at the store and get like
eight grand from the door at eight
thousand dollars you could track it
exactly to what families that went to
and then what they spent the money on to
like people go look I need to pay my
rent Don I need to get a car for this
done and I'm and we need to do it I'm
grateful to be alive
that's what I got it set up at the store
yeah well ruber
the Comedy Store already paid for the
drinks ass t-shirt that would be great
that's because the moms need it the
families need this [ __ ] Gino kickin
some speed weed yeah some CBB or we
could get CBD line and get involved if
you need them
I need that because that's all kids who
want CBD or whatever we get I got a
family in Pennsylvania where that's the
only thing there was actually a kid I
grew up with who reached out to me was
like I see what you're always doing he
goes here's my situation I'm low THC in
it so now he's happy yeah this is and it
works for this kid and it's his seizures
it's the only thing that worked yeah it
said listen it's so weird I forgot to
bring it with me this week on Kansas
City I have a 500 milligram CBD line in
my travel bag like a rub no I have the
my tongue at night uh-huh just as I'm
getting in that realm of yeah that after
the show jitters yep
CBD yeah your elevated the CBD and I
know a lot of people know Joey you need
THC in it listen I got enough THC on my
own
trust me when I put two tensions under
my tongue at night I got an hour an hour
15 minutes that's great it's a slow
saying but you know what I need to know
let me write for now yep I know what am
i doing my life okay and then you sleep
solid through the night I don't pee oh
that's great
wait till you turn 47 and every hour on
the hour you start peeing you know
different foods and different whatever
make sure whatever swell yeah your
prostate around 8:00 and the pee would
come out like my prostate would be
swallowed and then P will come out like
triples mm-hmm like that you standing
there for actually seven minutes I've
waked yourself up
Gillian can go back to sleep now and
there's some rights were [ __ ] like
after you fly mm-hmm
so after you fly you retain that water a
guy like me gets that water his legs
when I get to the hotel I put the
computer on my lay on the floor I land
on the bed with my legs higher to get
the runaround
forget it all night I'll be [ __ ] pen
guess what
dirt for Thursday night I got in
11 in Kansas City did the CBD dough
slept like a tank great I'm gonna get
even with the bed 11 o'clock at late
time Wow because I thought I was gonna
be up till [ __ ] 203 in the morning
yeah I was body gets all messed up a
little 31 30 I turn the lights off
that's when I had a hard and I got a
Friday lay in Kansas City I went to bed
without the CBD like [ __ ] two hours
until you sleep there you are peeing mom
and then Saturday I was so excited about
them I got back and I didn't and I
didn't sleep at all really and I slept
like three hours and I woke up to five
and what came out of my dick was two
pounds of [ __ ] urine drinking all
those waters during the show yeah
because the elevation in Denver - I need
to drink water oh my god when I got
there I took my pants off before the
shower
mmm I was watching the baseball game
when I threw my leg up on the bed and
something made me look at my legs I was
there for three hours that already my
skin was [ __ ] brutally dry out my
legs
I was like oh my god I mean yeah I got
there took my sweats off after the plan
and put shorts on we will write the SAMS
number three ah that dynasty was two
minutes uber was like five bucks ah
right there on the corner I 25% a little
break for a weekend like the doctors
like five hours going around the world
that's crying bro we went in to listen
we got off the plane in Denver what
upstairs if you go Felicia I'll call you
to find this I basically went back took
my computer I plugged it in plug through
the sleep apnea machine took the piss
wash my hands roll the joint went
downstairs mad that's how quick it was
there was one writing type of discussion
Herbert's and number three got there we
got a cool waitress I fell in love that
real I all I had for breakfast is over
meal that morning because I was prepared
i starved
I had a four-point protein bar on the
flight that my wife backs me on the
plane they're [ __ ] tremendous I knew
I was gonna kill some point
so I wasn't got a bowl of green chili
which is like 16 points that just add a
killer and then I opened up with the
chicken beef fajitas uh-huh I kept it
light I only ate one tortilla after the
rest I hate I didn't touch the cheese I
had although that is all I took the
salsa lettuce onion the South's and
their stomachs and all the sauce is to
die for
then we invited the waitress to the show
she nearly died and she came with my
mother and I bought the mother's
boyfriend oh that's great yes she came
to the show I texted my texted the bowl
of chili oh my that's fantastic that's
when you know Sam's number three guy
came with his dad I want to thank you
for saying hello another couple show
that when how is eating barbecue in
Kansas City I took a picture within
three minutes a girl came up and she's
like I can't believe I'm here with you
I noticed the plate well wow that's
awesome that means more to me than the
comedy show like that [ __ ] like my post
green chili and you show up to Sam's
number three out of respect that's you
got me that real connection it's the way
it was it was just like it's the best oh
my god oh my [ __ ] god we had that
happen in Reno this guy who worked at
the same one shop we went twice he knew
everyone from the podcast he knew me and
he wanted to start comedy and we offered
him free tickets and what we shall we
introduce him to like what we put him on
his path we put him on his comedy path I
was like John this is not a mistake this
is divine intervention you've been
thinking about comedy you have a comedy
notebook but you haven't done your first
open mic yet and we show up and we're
doing I thought you put him on stage no
he wouldn't do it he'd never been up yet
he hadn't been up yet so went but we
hooked him up with Wayne and Wayne was
like gave him us four shows he goes
we're gonna start you with these didn't
he Wayne open up the books for him or
something he I don't know if he got
books but he definitely knows well the
open mikes are now he knows Wayne so he
probably might and I just didn't hear
that person so weird I think Wayne gave
him days oh wow
divine intervention any career hmm it's
so life change and life gives you
little signals and you don't pay
attention to the reverse and all sudden
one day you just put in this situation
and that thing you wanted to do now
you're doing it
mm-hmm you know with me I wanted to do
it like me tell three people told me
yeah okay I get anxiety just thinking
about it like I wanted to do it so bad I
had a [ __ ] day job I was a roofer
that's hard work I was an estimator but
I still worked my ass I was the hardest
I had to work with my brother-in-law's
company I had to work on everybody else
and not people would say your brother
was exactly yeah I was climbing ladders
talking jobs getting coffee that's the
main goal taping everybody happy take of
estimation classes at night for [ __ ]
different companies I went into it you
know when I went in I went in he gave me
a tremendous salary am I gonna lie to
you he gave me a great salary that I did
not deserve but I knew I just couldn't
accept it I had worked I get no salary
so I became an estimator but calm he was
still ringing that we had a slow day and
I watched punch line and that was it Oh
a Tom Hanks yeah my [ __ ] heart broke
and I'm like you know like half crying
while I [ __ ] get married you know why
does life have to be so but I know the
balls to go on state so what difference
is it making life is fair that and I'm
gonna be a [ __ ] about getting on stage
life is never gonna be fair yeah i sat
there for six months i sat there for
maybe a year yeah without find out that
feeling and then I finally went into a
[ __ ] thing to get coffee and for some
reason to open up a notebook I'm I saw a
picture and he paid and it was talking
to my rose and success and do you want
to be a stand-up these are the comedy
stand-up courses and if you want me to
tell you that was divine intervention I
think it was if you want me to say it
was something else it you believe that
the Lord put that in my path whatever he
maybe Chinese black exactly Juliet
whatever that God is I don't want you to
go all what Joey's going off the
reservation thought oh my god no yeah
whatever that powers at the universe
because it was one of these things where
you take a newspaper go like that and
there was yeah come on you know it
wasn't like I got the loose paper and
said Oh what you know right a guy let
his kid
fired today and ended up I opened up the
middle just some habit yeah and there it
was so I think back now thank God for
whatever what would ever climb up put
that side up yeah what was your son well
I had so many of them but I remember
once uh Joe matarese I had met him at a
I got booed off stage at a place called
what was it was called the laugh house
in Philly on sound smart star there he
was want to give me a pep talk Jay big
Jay used to close it out there yeah my
first open mic ever
I got booed off stage was horrible what
was my first open mic at that place I'd
done a few like a year before and I'm
like that's it I'm not doing it but then
I had that bug like I was thinking about
it all week so then I went you know what
I'm not gonna perform I'll just go down
and watch then I went down and watch and
honestly it was Kevin Hart who gave me
like a pep talk come back know sign up
next week do it and then the headliner
that weekend was matarese who I had
heard about years before about some kid
from Philly that went to New York and
was doing good things so then I met
matarese at that show I came back to the
open mic was on Tuesday I came back
Friday or Saturday night the matarese
one got a slice of pizza with me and
gave me a pep talk he's like no just
this is how you do it and I want okay
and then it still took years for me to
really do it and then uh matarese
invited me up to New York once went to a
Yankee Red Sox Day game and I'm like
this what comedians do during the day
this is great that night we went to
Gotham that it just opened up because
one of his buddies heard that Seinfeld
was gonna do a popin
so then all the comics were hanging out
I wound up talking to Seinfeld and this
is like in 2099 something like that he's
like the biggest star in the world he
was very nice to me and then uh I came
to LA I went home I quit my job my buddy
that was supposed to move out here with
me he was too much of a he was too
afraid to quit his job he had a
government job he didn't want to give up
so now I had no job nothing I thought
I'd never do comedy again
and then our buddy and my mama said well
maybe Hollywood will come to you and I'm
like really and you think that's gonna
happen
I go to the iron sport gym my buddy
Jack's goes hey he was sold beer like
one of those guys he was we're having a
comedy contest and if you win it you get
to perform with Pauly Shore and I go get
out of here so I entered it I've been on
stage like maybe eight times won the
contest met Pauly and that's how I got
out here
God had to put a thousand sides I won
side didn't work for me I mean they were
I could go into details no difference at
all we should yeah twenty years later
yeah I'm working at his club he he that
comedy sir has been my family for the
last 19 years what's the name of your
charity again just what I'm asking for
people right now let's go to help Steve
help on Instagram and help Steve help on
Twitter if you go to help Steve help
calm you'll see the GoFundMe for the
family we're currently helping and in
the bio the GoFundMe there's the mom
then well I'm just asking people for a
dollar but for right now if they could
just follow us on Instagram Instagram
and Twitter then we'll start sharing
stories we'll figure out a way to make
it easy for people to give a buck and
then we're gonna do a podcast with all
things comedy throw a patron where you
get the podcast for a buck if you want
to donate at all 50 bucks or something
you'll get a custom t-shirt every month
whatever it is and that's aim way I know
you'd do this in the heart that's the
most important thing a lot of people do
this just to get [ __ ] a TV show in
this time oh Jesus yeah I think I'm
gonna do one you know a couple years ago
I got generous and I donated money to a
no-kill cat shelter like they were nice
to me so I gave me the money like I'm
done when I go I like to do a comedy
show somewhere donate a hundred percent
yeah get [ __ ] rogue and get yeah I
never like basically we really don't
appreciate your style economy or you as
a human or some [ __ ] oh my god
[Laughter]
listen we Pete Chavez - here on the
church yeah when somebody's honest with
you you can't get mad at them when the
church I met you got any dates for me
[ __ ] yeah I'm gonna be doing uh
Salt Lake City Thanksgiving weekend that
wise guys I'm gonna rerecord a CD what
it was in November 11th in the second
Tuesday of November in the belly room
then Salt Lake City and then I have Rick
Bronson's house a comedy in Scottsdale
first weekend the December then I have
the comedy work South the second weekend
of December beautiful I have nothing
coming up New Jersey sold out so all I
got is the Motor City casino
I'm the seven Detroit will [ __ ]
coming and on the eighth and ninth the
funny bone in Omaha I can't [ __ ] wait
to see my girl I love going for that
club when was the last time you went to
Omaha at ten years I love it that's a
great great comedy town takes you to a
great [ __ ] place to eat like
home-cooked like everybody's fat
diabetes apartment or on their ankles
are swollen
it's [ __ ] tremendous I love this
place thank you very much thank you
showing you your heartwarming your
honesty listen before we leave again the
church is brought to you by my bookie
listen why pick winners if you ain't
gonna bet that's why I go to my book
it's fast it's easy and they pay when
you win let's face it where you're
betting is just as important as who you
betting on right or wrong if you try to
bet on the NFL baseball MMA pfl whatever
the [ __ ] it is my bookies got it I
wouldn't be telling you guys to bet with
them if they weren't the best do the
smart thing if you're gonna bet football
this season that was my bookie just two
weeks away from pro [ __ ] basketball
and baseball playoffs are here you can
make a little money off the [ __ ]
Yankees or [ __ ] the Washington
Senators in the next couple of days do
you know you can bet games after the
kickoff of my bookie no you didn't know
if by the second half it looks like your
bet is gonna lose you can always take
the other side who does that my bookie
that's who if you're the type of guy
that likes to bet a little and win a lot
then we try a little parlay if for your
picks
Groo you multiply your winnings and no
matter how you're back the NFL season is
still the best time of the year why cuz
I got college football why cuz I got pro
basketball the first month the lines are
soft that's when you bet basketball the
first month the lines are slow up you
got the NHL you got NFL play I mean you
listen you got a plethora of [ __ ]
gambling I think my bookies got a site
where you could bet on to [ __ ]
praying mantises in Hong Kong under a
basement where the gods ain't for
hitting people with sticks you [ __ ] like
that
listen they even got a if all your pings
come through you multiply your winnings
if you better parlay and no matter how
you bet season it's the best time of the
year how many times we're gonna say that
anyway what I'm trying to say to you is
it's trying to make some [ __ ] Jesus
if you go to my bookie that Agee today
right now we're gonna double your first
deposit use promo code Church CH you are
CH to get 100 percent bonus and your
initial deposit up to $1,000 who does
that for you nobody [ __ ] so visit my
bookie dot AG today that's my bookie dot
AG and don't forget to use promo code
Church when creating your account to
claim your bonus all right you play you
win you get [ __ ] paid the church will
also love to welcome listen you know me
when Lee was doing his nine diets ago
when Lee did the vegetable [ __ ] thing
with the pickle juice and the [ __ ]
tendon beans [ __ ] when he was coming
here look at all sour look shakes but
with the blender juice add yeast icing
the juice diet remembers had got all
nice and small and look like my cat
super bad was nice and small back then I
remember him telling me one time what
was in it and I made kind of one at the
house and it tasted like listen after I
drank it I was like Chris corn now I was
ready to hang myself
I put the church's Roger you behind it
was terrible by suicide prevention and a
juice and don't be [ __ ] juice it what
we're talking about here is that let it
greens it's an awesome supplement that
gives you a
dick swinging energy listen if you're
not starting your day off with a blast
of vitamins you already lost go back to
bed your [ __ ] you're useless but if you
want to feel tip-top Magoo let a
thematic dreams do the dirty work they
got you covered in five critical areas
health energy and munity gonna help and
hormonal support the number one thing I
loved about them when I drank it was the
gut support the gut helped tremendous
you hear a little noises and [ __ ] you
can hit a little bugs disappearing from
the inside of your systems when you eat
that Mexican meat from a taco stand it's
got rice in it and [ __ ] who else takes
care you like that nobody athletic green
does in one scoop you get 75 count them
75 essential vitamins minerals
probiotics digestive enzymes raw silk
new foods mushrooms and a Whole Foods
they got everything
no more pill bottles of trying to choke
down a dozen apples it's all in there
the best part is the powder comes in an
easy-to-use travel pack you're gonna see
this I love this guys when I'm on the
road you throw them in your bag and you
know you'll be protected drinking
athletic greens is like a daily
insurance policy between me and my body
it tastes delicious I drink this and
then I can have a little fun and you can
relax because their ingredients ready
for this a plant-based sure if you're
likely on keto or likely gluten free you
can take this no chemicals no artificial
flavors no artificial preservatives no
artificial sweeteners no added sugar no
GMO or besides lactose sucrose dextrose
eggs yeast peanuts or animal products
these guys got you covered you need to
take care of yourself you need to be a
good friend to yourself and that's why I
recommend supplements everybody that
it's easy you just add cold water shake
it up you can take that banana and shove
it up your ass what are you waiting for
members of the church family get a
special offer right 20 free travel packs
valued at $79 with your first purchase
do me a favor just check out athletic
greens calm right now just go check them
out
read about and see what you think I'll
tell you what you're making a big
mistake if you don't go with that's for
the games to get your travel packs today
go to athletic greens comm slash church
athletic greens [ __ ] tremendous
I want to thank my bookie I want to
thank athletic greens I want to thank
CBD lime most of all I want to thank you
[ __ ] remember November 7th
Motor City casino so are you kidding me
or what and then the 8th and 9th I'm in
Omaha Nebraska at the funny bone I want
to thank Steve Simone I want to thank
the [ __ ] if he came to Denver I
[ __ ] love you they came to Kansas
City I [ __ ] love you and if you're
coming to Jersey I [ __ ] love you
thanks for being sold out I love your
[ __ ] have a great Tuesday
nobody could take dick from you you got
the church on the about check this
[ __ ] meal Lee